Trump has now said he will not sign the
pledge he can't do that to our pledges
that he is required to sign to support
the eventual nominee which means that
most likely he won't be in the debate
75 78 80 and other guys are at zero one
percent two percent three percent you do
say uh what's the upside am I going to
go up one point but they could go up you
know they're not dumb people they're
senators
their Governors their intelligent people
you have some very good people I think
you have some very good people and you
have some people I mean I have a problem
with the debate for another reason I
wouldn't sign the pledge why would I
sign a pledge of people on there that I
wouldn't have why would he sign the
pledge to say that he'll support the
eventual nominee well what about party
doesn't care about party Unity Trump
launched a hostile takeover the
Republican Party 2016 was a hostile
takeover he's not a lifelong Republican
he doesn't have any loyalty to the
Republican Party he took it over